Oh River babes it's lovely to see you
again
I'm your host Liana Galera and you're
watching the Sweetwater secrets preview
show for episode 219 chapter 32
prisoners now even though we are all in
mourning over midges death I hope you're
excited to be here
because today I've got the most adorable
interview with star Lily Reinhardt and
Camilla Mendez talking all about how
much they love Bea and me were actually
roommates in LA now I'm also gonna be
dropping three can't-miss clues about
episode 219 and they're going to send
you into full-on bug head detective mode
this is the best thing you've ever
written now before I jump into your top
hisses and kisses from the last episode
I just want to take a moment to thank
all of you river babes for keeping the
comments-section such a positive place
you know it takes a lot of time and
effort and energy to create two shows
for you each week but I do it because we
all love Riverdale and want a safe place
to share our theories likes and dislikes
for the week
now everyone's opinions are valid so
thank you all for spectin each other and
keeping Sweetwater secrets a fun place
for fans kisses to you river babes with
that said let's see what you had to say
about last week's musical episode now
kicking things off
Daphne Allen posted Oh kisses to Kevin
for having such a huge role in this it's
always so good to see him the subtle
Shoni vibes always amazing and cheryl
savageness also Madeleine Camilla and
Lily's voices though KJ definitely
proved he could dance and can we just
talk about Alice for a second how does
she always slay every episode so glad
that Josie and Cheryl made up and the MV
are back on track now her hisses the
black hood is back
no midges death hurt my heart for the
entire Riverdale family I loved her and
I sincerely hope she was the last black
hood victim though it's not likely
bloody likely and to that avvocato added
i mean moose and kevin can be together
now uh very true avocado a little savage
given the timing but I like where your
head's at town like Riverdale we don't
have a lot of options meanwhile Kathy
Ren is dropping a mind-blowing theory
writing OMG I bet the black hood is
house twin we know the blossoms are
family of twins and as much as I hate
Hal he's not the black hood Doug dun dun
I kind of loved that one
speaking of Hal Cooper Eminem 17 806
said I actually was happy that Hal got
Alice cuz bug head would be weird I ship
phallus but I don't want to don't fight
your phallus feelings run away from your
feelings
next up the Abby and Layla show
commented kisses to Jughead for rushing
over to Betty when midge was murdered
nobody notices that like why um I
noticed it it was such a sweet bug head
moment and I also noticed void vampires
comment who wrote did anyone else notice
at the end when everyone was panicking
they showed chick peaceful sitting on
his chair for a few seconds left
check gross and wrapping things up
Simone oomba said this episode saved the
season
Archie finally took his head out of his
aass Betty and Veronica made up Cheryl
got her HBIC fever back this episode had
me shook I agree and I loved that there
were so many kisses for Betty Ann
Veronica's rekindled friendship I adore
the fact that Lilly and cami are BFFs in
real life and here's what they told me
about what it's like to have to film be
in these fighting scenes it's hard with
with our characters when they fight we
love each other and we want these
characters to always be friends but this
is a drama and there's going
conflict and we understand that I think
we both want for you know continuing
episodes in the next season it's more
being be the season 2 was so focused on
families and I hope that in the coming
episodes it's very focused on the
friendship I think she's the only person
in the show who she and I can kind of
like understand this whole life together
and kind of sort through it together and
that's always been like the biggest
benefit really I think fans love to see
kami and I work together and I love we
love to work with you talking about you
talking about you you guys are rooming
together have you guys should be
decorating like are you going to Ikea
together our niche
we don't have time for that time to I'm
gonna live in a furnace rental for the
foreseeable future for the rest of my
life yeah cuz we had talked at the
beginning of the season did you ever get
to have your pizza and Lizzie McGuire
movie night
well now we're gonna now we're
definitely gonna Liz Maguire night thank
you we need to watch a Cinderella story
as well hey girls Cheetah Girls what
else we got got a lager we got a lot to
work on being less
you guys are the best you say hi to fans
who love DNV thanks for loving this
beautiful friendship stand by them okay
cutest roomies ever I just love them now
what is your favorite part about lily
and camis real-life friendship share
with me in the comments below now let's
shift our attention to this week's
episode chapter xxxii prisoners because
based off of the promo it looks like
things are really starting to heat up as
we head into the end of the season your
days are numbered
also NYX eight suck returns blasts but
let's focus on something positive right
now and because I'm gonna give you three
clues that you need to know about this
week's episode here we go number one the
quest for revenge takes a dark turn but
one character will finally see the light
number two
grab the tissues because one actors
performance will shock you to your core
and break your heart at the same time
and number three as the town mourns
Mitch's death one family learns the
truth of a fallen angel and there you go
this is an hour that you definitely do
not want to miss so check back with me
for the Sweetwater Secrets after-show
for episode 219 so weekend for wreak out
over the biggest bombshells for now
please give this video a like and then
hit the comments to try and decipher my
three clues plus what are your
predictions for the rest of the season
sharing is caring and I'll see you soon
river babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]